nadège bonjour alors comment se déroule
la manifestation
bah écoutez olivier la manifestation
touche à sa fin le personnel soignant
est retourné au travail mais on a quand
même plusieurs dizaines de personnes ici
devant à cet hôpital pédiatrique
parisien est bien à vouloir continuer
cette manifestation ici avec un
dispositif de sécurité toujours aussi
important en a une dizaine
plusieurs dizaines de policiers et de
crs et des membres de la brague
également un présent ici pourra éviter
bien que la situation ne dégénère que la
manifestation est bien atteignent
d'autres d'autres rues parisiennes
donc on va la manifestation qui se
déroule dans le calme est les soignants
et bien ont réclamé aujourd'hui plus de
moyens financiers c'est la deuxième fois
en une semaine et qu'ils se réunissent à
ces soignants ils craignent en
particulier le retour à la situation
d'avant qu'ovide le sous-effectif le
sous investissement est les salaires au
rabais les conditions de travail
difficiles beaucoup de membres
d'associations de gilet jaune et des mdd
personnalités politiques ont fait le
déplacement aujourd'hui à cette
manifestation et personnalités
politiques des députés de la france ont
soumis ce plus précisément je vous
propose de les écouter pas au manifeste
pour faire entendre notre voix parce que
pour l'instant on entend surtout la voix
du gouvernement qui est en train de
faire une communication comme quoi tout
a été formidable et
nous on est là pour dire que tout n'a
pas été formidable loin de là il ya eu
des scandales
pendant toute cette pandémie et on est
là pour marteler nos revendications
parce que pour le gouvernement les ne
les entends toujours pas il parle
d'augmentation de salaires mais sous
conditions ça va être du travailler plus
pour gagner plus c'est sait déjà ce
qu'on fait on est tous en train de faire
des heures supplémentaires pour arrondir
les fins de mois
mais c'est pas que ça compte dans le
monde on veut un vrai budget hospitalier
ça parle pas de budget hospitalier du
tout alors c'est vrai que taper dans les
mains aux fenêtres c'est bien mais j'ose
espérer que les citoyens et citoyennes
ne vont pas s'arrêter là ils vont
réellement prendre possession nous le
gilet jaune
on profitera de tout
les motifs tous les raisons qui nous
permettront de nous exprimer de soutenir
les autres mécontents et là je crois que
il ya urgence à ce que les choses
bougent car le ton se durcit partout
autour de nous les forces de police et
les contrôles plus de niches plus de
personnel et des augmentations de
salaires c'est ce que réclame vous
l'aurez compris le personnel hospitalier
a21 robert debré pour travailler dans de
meilleures conditions alors que vous le
voyez elle derrière moi et bien cette
manifestation aujourd'hui cette deuxième
édition de jeudi colère se poursuit ici
même avec un dispositif de sécurité
toujours aussi à important on a des
policiers qu'ils veulent à tout prix
éviter que la situation ne dégénère et
que des groupes de manifestants et bien
continuent de manifester
au delà de ce secteur là merci beaucoup
nadège pour toutes ces précisions nadège
abderrazak en direct devant l'hôpital
robert debré dans le xixème
arrondissement de la capitale